IntroWhen it comes to Disney movies, people
usually fall into two groups: those who think
that the studio releases nothing but family-friendly
adventures and important lessons, and those
who see suspicious jokes, messages, or meanings
below the surface. The studio will never confirm
or deny just how many outlandish fan theories
actually do have some truth to them, but the
ideas alone are worth investigating. Here
are Screen Rant's 10 Movie Theories That Completely
Change Disney Films.
Toy Story
Most of the series is spent following the
toys of Toy Story, but their owner, Andy,
is just as important. But the adventures he
shares with his childhood toys - and the need
to give them up as he gets older - may run
in his family. In Toy Story 2, fans found
out that Jessie was originally owned by a
girl named Emily, before she was given away.
But some fans have claimed that Pixar makes
it perfectly clear that Emily is really Andy's
mom. In the first story, Andy is playing with
Woody while wearing Jessie's hat - the same
one Emily played with when she was younger.
Since 30 years have passed since Emily gave
her up, it makes Andy's mom the right age,
and delivers a happy ending to Jessie's story
that fans never even noticed.
Belle & Jane
It's obvious that the leading ladies of Beauty
& The Beast and Tarzan have plenty in common:
their hair, fair features, love of the color
yellow, and a knack for taming wild men. But
what if those similarities aren't just coincidence?
When the gorillas are trashing Jane and her
father's camp, the teapot set from Beauty
& The Beast is visible - the one that Mrs.
Potts and Chip were cursed to remain until
The Beast was loved. So, did Jane bring a
French relative's china on her trip? Or is
it all from a shared family set? The time
periods align, since the Eiffel Tower in Beauty
& The Beast proves the movie is more modern
than you would think. If it isn't, could Jane
be the grand daughter of Belle and the Beast?
We'll let the fans decide.
Aladdin
The tale of a prince in diguise and magical
wishes is narrated by Genie, but what if the
story isn't set in Agrabah centuries in the
past? What if it's actually set thousands
of yearsin the future? When he's first released,
Genie claims that he's been imprisoned in
the lamp for thousands of years. So how does
he know to make jokes about modern movies
and celebrities? Believe it or not, some fans
believe Genie was trapped in our time, and
waited ten thousand years, as the world advanced,
and a world-ending disaster set mankind back
by millennia. It's a wild theory, and there's
no evidence, right? Well, the modern stop
signs buried in the sand of the companion
video game might actually back this theory
up…
Brave Boo
There's no character more adorable than Boo,
the little girl who refused to be scared by
the stars of Monsters, Inc. And even though
she wound up back at home in the end, leaving
her best friend behind cut deep. So what if
she refused to give up looking for him as
she got older? One fan theory asks if the
teleporting-door technology used in Monsters,
Inc isn't just moving monsters through space
- but time, as well. How Boo figured it out
is a mystery, but the theory claims that she
picked up plenty of magic along the way, eventually
landing in the forest of Brave. There she
grew old, carving pictures of Sully and the
Pizza Planet truck. When Merrida comes to
ask for help, she escapes the only way she
knows how: by traveling across time and space
using a simple door.
Up, Up, And Away
No Pixar fan will forget the opening scenes
of Up, following Carl Fredericksen fall in
love, grow old, and eventually lose his wife.
Living alone, it's only a matter of time until
Carl's temper gets him committed. But instead,
he escapes to see the world using thousands
of balloons tied to his house. Or does he?
It's too sad to believe, but some fans think
Carl actually died the night before he was
headed to Shady Oaks, and the adventure is
his journey to the afterlife. We don't know
if that's an even more poetic look at the
movie, or just doubling down on the tears.
Wreck-it Ralph
As entertaining as the classic game characters
may be, it was Calhoun from Hero's Duty who
stole the show. And she came with a tragic
backstory, too: seeing the man of her dreams
eaten by a Cy-bug just seconds before they
would have been married. She's still a soldier,
and took her anger out on the bug right then
and there. But wait - Cy-bugsbecomethe
things they eat: whether it's a gun, candy,
or an actual person. It didn't take long for
fans to realize that the Cy-bug that killed
Calhoun's fiance actuallybecame himseconds
later - forcing her to kill the twisted, insectoid
murderer version of him. And that puts a completely
different spin on the rest of her story - not
to mention a more satisfying ending.
Snow White Gets Tangled?
The Evil Queen's name says it all in Disney's
classic Snow White, when her need to be the
most beautiful woman in her kingdom leads
her up against the lovely Snow White. She
takes the form of an ugly old woman, and sets
out to deceive the girl with false promises.
Once Disney fans realized that the Evil Queen
actually looks a lot like Gothel from Tangled,
they also noticed that they're both obsessed
with staying young and beautiful, and taking
advantage of young girls to make it happen.
So what if they're the same woman? Having
failed to get the job done with one Disney
princess, the Queen just moved onto the next?
It's not as exciting a theory as some, but
helps link Disney's oldest movie to one of
its most recent hits.
Toy Story 3
Out of all the Disney theories, people claiming
that Toy Story 3 is just one massive analogy
for the Nazi's treatment of Jewish citizens
seems hard to believe. But even if the movie
isn't as clear a reference as some fans claim,
the actual plot is hard to ignore. First,
the toys are abandoned by their guardians,
then gathered up and sent to a horrible place
where they're regularly abused, and eventually
wind up inches away from death - before allies
from a faraway land show up to literally pull
them out of the fire. They even end up at
a new home, where toys like them are protected.
That may just be a universal story lived through
by all kinds of people throughout history,
but given the parallels, this theory isn't
going away any time soon.
The Lion King
When the Lion King was released, some people
started pointing out that the similarities
with a popular Shakespeare story were too
obvious. The Lion King would basically be
“Hamlet” with animals. If we look at the
details, this theory starts making a lot of
sense. In Hamlet, the King is killed by Claudius,
Hamlet’s uncle, but the circumstances of
his death are kept secret. Hamlet has two
goofy friends named Rosencrantz and Guildenstern
and ends up getting revenge for his father’s
death by stabbing his uncle and forcing him
to drink poisonous wine. Even if it’s heavily
influenced by the play, The Lion King remains
one of the best animated films in history.
The Frozen Theory
Frozen is one of the most celebrated Disney
films of the last 10 years and it’s filled
with references from other Disney movies.
You probably heard about this one before since
we covered it in detail in our documentary
entitled “The Secret Relations Between Disney
Movie Princesses”, but it’s worth mentioning
again. The theory explores how Anna & Elsa
might be related to Rapunzel, Cinderella and
Ariel to name a few, but the bombshell comes
when there is a possible link to another Disney
character… When Anna and Elsa’s parents
leave on their ship and never come back, the
creators of Frozen gave people a clue when
they said on Reddit that the parents shipwreck
on an island and have a child that ends up
getting raised by gorillas… Tarzan, making
him Anna & Elsa’s long lost brother... Make
sure you check out our documentary by clicking
on the link for more details on this amazing
theory!
Those are some of our favorite theories about
the real meaning of hit Disney movies, but
which ones have we missed? Let us know in
the comments, and remember to subscribe for
more videos like this one. Thanks!